do you have big goals that you want to
accomplish this year i recently made a
video on how to make 2022 your best year
but in this video i wanted to dive
deeper than that and actually talk about
the specifics of how you go about
carrying out those goals because we can
sit down and plan out our goals and
write down lists all we want to but when
it comes to actually carrying those
things out and putting them into
practice that's when the going gets
tough so in this video i want to share
with you five lessons that i have
learned through building our own home
and hopefully those lessons can be
helpful to you so you can achieve your
goals in 2022. lesson number one to eat
an elephant you have to take it one bite
at a time we built our home as our own
general contractors with no prior
building experience and we did have some
help for major things like foundation
for example but we did a great majority
of the work ourselves and this quickly
began to feel draining a daunting task
not only physically but also emotionally
and these were the words of my mentor
when i broke down because i felt like
there was no end in sight
she said to eat an elephant you have to
take it one bite at a time sure these
words didn't fix the problem but they
gave me a new perspective big projects
or big goals may seem impossible in the
process because we get physically
exhausted and emotionally drained and we
also tend to get impatient because we
don't see the progress that we're making
when we're the ones running the race
what we did to combat this feeling of
running in place was to focus on smaller
tasks rather than the big picture so
instead of focusing on the giant
elephant in front of us in this case a
finished house we instead focused on
smaller tasks such as this week we will
lay flooring and actually i share more
information on my previous video so
check that one out if you want to know
more information about how to go about
setting goals if you have big projects
in mind look for ways to break them into
smaller chunks this can help you feel a
sense of accomplishment as you actually
achieve these steps instead of feeling
weighed down because you haven't yet
arrived to your end result but before we
go on i want to know what goals do you
have for this year let me know in the
comments lesson number two self-care is
a must not a maybe initially we thought
that we could both work our full-time
jobs work on the house on the weekends
and any day that we were off early
manage our business and manage our
personal lives and after a few months of
this it was physically and emotionally
draining and not only that but my
husband actually ended up injured he had
to take two weeks of work off unpaid and
this not only set us back as far as the
house project went and all of the uh
progress that we had already completed
but then we had added medical bills on
top of that what i mean by all of this
is that if you put your health on the
back burner thinking when i finish this
i'll rest more or once this is over i'll
eat better or once i get through this
i'll start exercising
you might not live to get there or you
may just get there only to find yourself
ill and not able to enjoy the lifestyle
that you thought you would have because
you focused on the end result
more than the process of actually
getting there be careful that you don't
take your ambitions to extremes because
unfortunately some people will find
themselves working extremely hard
throughout their lives and skimping on
their health in the process only to find
themselves paying for it all back and
then some in medical expenses and their
health is not something that they can
necessarily recover my husband talks
about a man that he once knew that
actually used to say this that he would
eat the banana peels because he paid for
that too and this was a person who
worked extremely hard day in and day out
but he would skimp on his health in
order to save money he actually did
accomplish his dream or what he thought
was his dream and he became a
millionaire and he had all the things
that he wanted but he did not achieve
the lifestyle that he had hoped for he
ended up dying early in sickness my
husband says that he knew him at the
time when he was in his death bed and he
said now i have all the money that i
ever wanted but i can't even eat salt
the cheapest of foods so make your
health a priority and stop making
excuses for why you can't it matters now
lesson number three those who succeed
learn to adapt people often tell me how
nice that you could build your own house
and have everything the way that you
wanted and well that wasn't exactly the
case anybody that's ever built a house
will know that you have to be able to
adapt to change and really i think it
applies to life as well rarely is there
ever going to be a situation where
everything just falls into place and
everything just happens perfectly the
way that we had planned for an example
that i can relate to you about our house
is that we had a three inch mistake in
our framing just three inches but that
completely threw off our kitchen
cabinetry we the layout that we had and
the piping there was not a cabinet that
we could fit within the corner of our
walls and we had to figure out a way to
work around that because we looked and
looked and we didn't have the money to
pay for custom and so that is actually
how we ended up with our floating
shelves so we found a way to work around
this situation to make it work for our
benefit instead of being stressed out of
uh now what are we going to do so it
wasn't what we had planned i didn't at
all expect that we would have a floating
shelf that wasn't what i envisioned but
we found a way to work around that
problem and adapt there will be times in
your life when things do not go the way
that you plan and adapting to those
situations can often imply sacrifice the
point is not to get stuck in a pity
party and leave the project altogether
it's about looking at the situation and
accepting it for what it is then adapt
lesson number four all work and no play
destroys relationships by this i'm
mainly speaking to people in
relationships but i think that it can
also apply to friendships as well when
we were building our house my mentor
warned me that starting a big project
like building a house or starting a
business is often the cause of divorce
and this idea was honestly strange to me
and me being the nerd that i am i
researched into it and to my surprise
she was correct this topic is quite
large and probably deserves a video of
its own so for now i will only talk to
you about two things that you should
watch out for just like we mentioned in
lesson number two if you become so
obsessively focused on a project that
you don't even take care of your own
self
what does that say about the
relationships around you
are people getting the best version of
you when you're around or are they
getting a grumpy tired complaining half
asleep seep warmer and number two are
you actually present and i use this word
intentionally because just because
you're in a room doesn't mean that
you're actually there and present in
conversation with the people that are
around you and this is actually
something that my husband and i
struggled with when we were building the
house because it seemed like we couldn't
be in the same room together in any kind
of situation and not talk about the
house it truly became an obsession and
having goals and projects and ambitions
is wonderful it's great but sometimes
without even realizing it we can get
into this gray zones and distance
ourselves from other people and before
we even know it we've missed out on our
relationships so take care of your
relationships nurture your relationships
because truly that's all that we have i
assure you that if you live in a
bajillion dollar house but you're all
alone and you have nobody to talk to
nobody to relate with that would feel
pretty darn lonely so take care of the
people that you have around you do still
follow your goals and pursue those goals
but make time for play schedule quality
time with the people that you love and
be present and if you can shut phones
and technology off during that time even
better and lastly lesson number five the
diligent work once and the lazy work
twice does it seem a bit odd that a lazy
person would work twice as hard as
someone else let me explain have you
ever tried to bring all your groceries
into the house at once because you
wanted to avoid having two trips and
then have a bacteria and food roll all
over the place this actually happened to
me a couple years back when we lived in
a downhill area and i had to scavenge
around trying to grab all of my
groceries as my neighbors were just
probably looking at me like this crazy
lady i had to run all the yard trying to
get my groceries only because i didn't
want to make two trips to grab my bag
and put it in the house anyone else ever
done that like come on i'm not the only
one am i and i think that the same
applies to big projects and just life in
general because when we take shortcuts
or put little effort in what we do not
only does it leave little hope that
we'll actually achieve greatness but
it's much more likely that things will
go wrong think about it this way if you
buy a product or a service from somebody
and the product is sloppy and thrown
together or done halfway you're probably
not going to purchase from them again if
you want to succeed in your major goals
excellence has to be where you set the
bar so those are my five lessons to
share with you for today i hope that you
found this video helpful and if so
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
so that you won't miss when i post a new
video and let us know in the comments
what are some things that you do to help
you achieve your goals please share in
the comments so that we can all learn
from each other i hope you achieve all
your goals and then some thank you so
much for watching and i can't wait to
hear from you in the comments and see
you in the next video bye for now
[Music]
you